>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Good morning.
My name is Rachel Hartigan
Shea editor
of the Washington Post Book World.
The Washington Post is very
proud to be a charter sponsor
of the National Book
Festival and I am very pleased
to introduce the next author.
Nell Irvin Painter is one
of the leading historians
in and of this country.
She is a professor of American
history at Princeton University
where she has also served as
director of Princeton's program
in African-American studies.
She's written seven books
including Sojourner Truth,
Standing at Armageddon which is
a history of the progressive era
and The History of White People.
In The History of White People
she argues that I quote,
"race is an idea, not a fact" and
traces the development of that idea
from classical times to the present.
Not one to shy away
from a challenge,
she has arm wrestled Stephen Colbert
on TV and is currently working
on an MFA in painting at the
Rhode Island School of Design.
Please join me in welcoming
Nell Irvin Painter
[ Applause ]
>> Hi folks.
Thank you much for staying.
Glad to see you all.
I'm not going to read from my
book, The History of White People.
I'm gonna talk about it a little bit
and then leave some
time for questions.
And if you have a question,
please use the mics.
So if you already have a question,
you can go to the mic now.
I often get ask why did I write
The History of White People
as if my body would stop me
from any area of inquiry.
I'm a historian and I
write on what I want.
I was thinking when I
started this book back
into the 20th century why are
white people called Caucasian?
Have any of you asked yourself that?
Do you know why?
No. And this was when the Russ--
well, it's still happening.
The Russians and the
Chechens and Chechnyas
in the caucuses were
having tremendous struggle.
So, why are White Americans
called Chechens?
Well, I did find the answer.
The answer took me to Germany, took
me to Germany in the 18th century.
Now, the idea of race was
invented in the 18th century.
It doesn't go back to antiquity.
There were not White
people in antiquity.
But since so many people thought
that, I thought I should address it.
So my book actually starts
with the Greeks and the Romans
and their commentary on the
people who became Europeans.
And what the Greeks and
Romans discovered were people
who lived in various ways.
For the Greeks they talk
about what we call culture.
And for the Romans who
ward in various ways
because the Romans were imperialist
and we're very interested
in who was a good fighter
and who could help
and who had to be vanquished.
I followed this German idea into the
United States via Madame de Stael
who was a French intellectual
and Thomas Carlyle
who was a British intellectual
and Ralph Waldo Emerson.
So I spent a long time with Ralph
Waldo Emerson who was the kind
of genius of 19th century
White race theory.
Ralph Waldo Emerson didn't have a
great deal to say about Black people
but he had a lot to
say about White people.
Now, in the 19th century
the idea prevailed
that there were many White races.
So there were people who
were considered white.
No one can question their whiteness.
Very clearly the Irish were white.
Very clearly people
descended from English people
or Scottish people were
white or German people.
But they belong to different races.
They were white but they
belong to different races.
So for instance, the Irish
Catholics were thought to belong
to the Celtic race
and people descended
from English people were thought
to belong to the Saxon race.
And the Saxons were
better than the Celts.
It was not until the middle
of the 20th century which many
of us remember vividly that the
idea of one big White race came
into being in which everybody
who was white was the
same as everybody else.
And it's not an accident that
that happened through politics.
It happened through the
national mobilization
of the Great Depression,
the Second World War
and the federal policies
crafted after Second World War.
So one big White race is
an idea based in politics.
My book is called The
History of White People.
Let me say a few things
that it does not do.
It does not talk very much
about people who are not white.
There is very little about
African-Americans, Indians, Asians,
Latinos, people of color.
They do appear from time to time and
they appear very much at the end.
But it really is a book
about the construction
of the idea of White races.
It's not a book in which I
get to beat up White people
for the bad things
they've done to others.
And when I started, sometimes
people would say to me,
are you writing it
as a Black person?
And I would say, I would
get huffy and I would say,
I'm writing it as a historian.
But I realize that what they meant,
are you going to use this
book to settle scores?
No. I don't settle scores.
It's not about what White
people have done to others.
So, it's not very much
about Black people,
which is what we usually
think of in the United States
when we think about race.
When people hear the world
race they automatically jump
to African-American
history to Black people.
This is not my book.
What I did learn was that race is
an idea that is used to create,
at worst, to create bad separation
and to rank people
and to stigmatize.
It can be used as a tool of hatred.
It can be used as a tool of racism.
Sometimes race is a source of pride.
It can be a source of identity
in which people rally around
and find themselves together
in difficult circumstances.
It can be a response to
racism, racial pride.
But wherever the situation
occurs, race functions
to identify difference, to
separate, even at best it separates.
And it's always used loosely
but it says these are people
who are permanently this
way and these are people
who are permanently that way.
Sometimes it says these are people
who are permanently
like this and like that.
So I learned as I worked
on this book about 10 years
that whether the racism
question are colored
or the racism question are
white, that race is a tool
of differentiation and separation.
Someone asked me when I was doing
my book tour earlier this year
if I favored a national
debate on race.
Let me ask you.
Let's take a vote.
Do you think it's a good idea for us
to have a national
discussion about race?
If you think yes, put your hand up.
If you think no, put your hand up.
If you're not sure,
put both hands up.
[Laughter] We got a lot of not sure.
Yeah. If you had asked me that
before I worked on my book,
I probably would have said,
yeah, it's a good idea
because we need to clear the air.
But then when I realized how
these ideas-- and race is an idea,
it is not a biological fact.
It is an idea.
>> As I worked on the history of
this idea, I began to change my mind
and I now no longer favor the
idea of the discussion of race.
I would much prefer
that we had a discussion
of the various conditions,
concerns, actions, thoughts,
opinions, wishes that we share.
I would much prefer that
we de-emphasize difference
and reemphasize likeness.
I much prefer that we work--
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
I much prefer that we think about
what holds us together so that
in this moment of national
crisis we can work together.
I wanna stop here with
the word together
and invite questions or comments.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes.
>> Thank you, Professor.
>> You're very welcome.
>> That was very-- that was-- one
of the ones who put their hands
in the air for we should
have a discussion and then I
like to change my answer
to what you just said.
>> Okay.
>> So, I was wondering since
we were talking about it,
the word White people,
the word Black people
and I heard you use the word
African-American and I wonder
if we're ready to maybe
stop using that expression
and start using the word Black more.
I don't-- I wondered just
as a black person yourself--
>> Yeah.
>> -- if you feel like that's a
comfortable way to be labeled.
>> The book that I published before
the White book was the Black book.
[Laughter] It's called
Creating Black Americans:
African-American History and Its
Meanings, 1619 to the Present.
And in that book, I
did use the word black.
And I use it because it's
a more encompassing word
and a less cumbersome
word than African-American
or all these other terms.
The reason it really stuck out, I
remember facing a class at Princeton
in which there were several
students of African descent.
Some of them were people
whose ancestors,
whose African ancestors left
involuntarily in the 18th century.
So they were Americans
with very deep roots.
Others had themselves been brought
to the Untied States as children
or their parents were immigrants.
So we talked about
nomenclature and we said, well,
what do you call brown colored
people of African descent
with deep American roots?
They said, oh, those
are African-Americans.
So what do you call brown
colored people of African descent
who came from Africa last week?
And they said, oh, those are
African-African-Americans.
[Laughter] So I'm thinking about
my book and the length of the book
and the number of words
I can get there
and I'm thinking how long
African-African-American is
in Caribbean African-Americans
and Latino African-Americans,
you know, so I just used Black.
Yes?
>> Hi. When you read
about current statements
by political leaders regarding
immigration and Islam and so on,
is there a period of American
history that seems most instructive
to you and what does it teach us?
>> Yeah. The current brouhaha over
immigration to my mind sounds just
like the period right
after the First World War
and this was a period of
hostility and hysteria
against immigrants from Europe.
And the racist as people
said were the Jewish race,
the Slavic race, the Italian.
Actually, there were
two Italian races.
There was the north Italian
race and south Italian race.
These were considered racist
and they actually had been
scientifically certified
to be intellectually inferior.
And that hysteria actually
led to a cutting off
of European immigration first
in 1921 and then in 1924,
so it sounds to me like 1919, 1920,
1921 until about the mid '20s.
Yes?
>> In talking about the
development of the concept of the
"White race" you said this developed
largely after World War II.
And you said, one other things
you said that contributed to it
in the addition to the word itself
was national policies and I wonder
if you could explain a little
bit what you meant by that.
>> Certainly, national policies.
During the 19 teens, in the
early part of the 20th century,
there was not a lot of political
mobilization to get people voting,
and particularly not
to get immigrants
and the children of
immigrants voting.
But during the Great Depression,
as Franklin Roosevelt and his team
of democrats tried to get
some heft on their side,
they mobilized this group
of naturalized Americans
or their children who had
been born in the United States
who were of the working class.
They were workers and they tended
to vote democratic when they voted.
So there was first a
mobilization of voters
on the democratic side
during the Great Depression
and that made possible the new
deal and continuing the new deal.
During the Second World War there
was an even greater emphasis
on national unity in order to pursue
the goals of the Second World War
and the Second World War
was a war against fascists
and Nazis and racial states.
And so there was a ground swell
of culture partly fostered
by the federal government but
largely because many Americans felt
that we needed to pull together.
It was a kind of multiculturalism
of [inaudible] before the word.
So that came out of
the Second World War.
And then after the Second World War,
there were two very important
policies that created the suburbs.
One was the Federal Housing
Administration which was not new
but took on a very important
new role as a guarantor
of mortgage lending, and
the Veterans Administration.
And this is the GI Bill of Rights.
These were administered in
a cruelly racist fashion
and they underwrote the suburbs
in a way that White people
of any background were able
to get this wonderful 30 year fixed
rate mortgages low down payment.
And people living in mixed
neighborhood, city neighborhoods,
Black neighborhoods could not.
Remember that it was not illegal
to discriminate in lending
and housing policies until 1968.
So the suburbs became White land.
People who had been part
of these many white races,
and the cities became Black land.
And then there's Malcolm X who
always talked about the White man.
He didn't say the south
Italian has been oppressing.
You know, he said the White man.
So the postwar era really cemented
this sense of a Black world
and a White world separated
by a [inaudible].
Yes?
>> Hi. First of all
I do own your book.
I haven't read it yet but
after this I'm going to.
I wanted to address two things.
First of all you talked about that
when you were writing the book,
people were coming to you and saying
is this something that you're going
to use to settle a score.
Curious, was that audience
that came to say
that to you, was it generational?
Did you have older people that
were saying that, younger people,
or was it across the board?
>> Older people.
>> Okay. Of whom I am
a card carrier member.
[Laughter] But I must say
that has changed and for
that I wanna thank
the American people.
>> Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Another question?
>> The second question
was when you talk
about race being the
culmination of race
and the White race per se
being a political thing.
My question is and you kinda--
just kind of dovetailing with the
gentleman before me talked about.
If it was a political thing and it
was meant not only to get people
to vote a certain way but
was also meant to entitle.
If you have a situation
where that is happening,
what is going to encourage
people that are entitled
to have a conversation
about equality?
>> I don't know.
[ Pause ]
>> Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yes?
>> Yes. I have a comment.
I have two of my grandchildren are--
>> Can you speak a little more?
I can't quite hear you.
>> Two of my grandchildren
are European, Southeast Asian,
Indian and African-American,
and so they aren't a race.
They are not a race.
And I discussed their
ethnic backgrounds
and I don't understand why we don't
replace the term race with ethnicity
because we do all have
different ethnic backgrounds.
I'm German and Irish.
My grandchildren have like
five ethnic backgrounds,
and that's the current
state of America.
So the discussion of race
is really anachronistic.
Any comment?
>> The discussion of race has
never made sense except as a means
of ranking people, as
differentiating people.
And the means and the
discussion have always differed
so there's never been any scientific
or nonscientific agreement
on how many human races there are
on how many White races
there are on how you tell.
So in the 20th century, and
I used to have my students
at Princeton do this, in the
early 20th century the way
to tell various White
races was to measure heads.
So if you had a round
head that was flat
in the back you were
probably an Alpine.
Okay. If you had a long head and
you were blond and blue eyed,
then you were a Teutonic.
And if you had a long
head and you had dark hair
and dark eyes you were
a Mediterranean.
Any of you heard of those races?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Okay.
But most of you I suspect have not.
But those were important scientific
terms in the early 20th century.
So the means of differentiating
and the names and all
that never has there
been an agreement.
It is race has always been a
figment of the cultural imagination,
not something in the body.
And certainly as the question
you pointed out, not permanent.
So today we are faced
with many children.
In fact, some grown ups with
very complicated backgrounds.
Now, in the 20th century, if you
were brown and you identify this
as Black or African-American
or colored,
you could have all
kinds of ancestors.
So most of us who say we're Black
or African-American have ancestors
from three continents, from Africa,
from America and from Europe.
And in fact historians say
that if you can trace your
American ancestry back to the middle
of the 19th century, you too,
no matter how you identify,
have ancestors from three
continents, at least, at least.
So we've always been mixed up.
Human beings have been
walking and moving
since human beings
became human beings.
Human beings became human beings
in Africa and started walking
and people have been walking
and moving and migrating
and I won't use the more
graphic Anglo-Saxon term for it
but they've been having sex.
[Laughter] And they've been having
sex with lots of different people.
So everybody is mixed and
this is not a new thing.
You ask the question
about the word ethnicity.
I hear this being substituted
from time to time for race.
It's seems like they're kinder,
gentler word and that's
fine with me.
Yes?
>> Professor Painter, my
name is Olivia McDavid
Blackamore [phonetic].
So I'm a living, walking Blackamore.
And that's what I've
always called myself--
>> Yes.
>> -- more so than African-American.
But we do know that the Africans
went into Europe and other countries
and intermingle and intermarried.
Could you tell us a
little more about that
and how we're connected
with the White race?
>> Well, there is no such
thing as a White race.
>> Okay.
>> There is no such
thing as a Black race.
Races are things that people make up
in order to differentiate you or me
or somebody else from somebody else.
It's a classification,
a taxonomical issue.
So as people moved, some settled.
And when you settle
you start to change.
Have you ever noticed how
differently younger people sound
from us when they talk?
And that's just change
is how people are.
So it all happened one by one.
You have sex, one-- no.
I was going to say you have sex one
person at a time but then I realized
that you can have a lot of
sex with a lot of people.
But generally you have sex with
one person at a time and what
that produces or the situation
under which it occurs,
sex can be a loving
close bond making event
but it can also be a rape or
something profoundly traumatic.
So sex occurs in all kinds
of situations among
all kinds of people.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Yes?
>> First of all Professor,
thank you for coming.
>> Thank you.
>> This seems to be a common
theme but I come from this area
like I think many of us come and
it's more multicultural area now,
and so it seems to me that the
battles of the '60s and '70s
and the '80s have started to
be reflected in my children,
our children's generation.
They seem to be much more
comfortable crossing the lines
with each other.
>> Yes.
>> So as a historian, are
you hopeful for the future?
Is-- are we marching
forward as a nation?
>> As a historian I-- no.
As a human being, I am hopeful.
I'm an optimist.
If I weren't an optimist, I
would have been long gone.
As a postmodern historian I say
that we don't always get
better as time goes on.
We don't-- progress
is not automatic,
so I don't know what's going
to happen in the future.
However, I will say that the
taxonomy of race is breaking down.
The clearest way to
see the breakdown is
with the classification
called Hispanic or Latino.
So if you see Hispanic
Latino, there's an asterisk
and it says Hispanic
Latinos can be of any race.
And something like 6 to 10 percent
of Latinos answering the 2000
census checked some other race.
That's a lot of people.
A lot of people are some other race.
So we are going to
be seeing other ways.
For myself if I were
designing it I would ask what
about family wealth
and what about income?
Because I think that's
where our policies need
to go but I don't design it.
>> Thank you.
>> We have time for
one more question.
>> Ah, okay.
Which would be [inaudible]?
>> Good morning.
I live in DC, predominantly
Black city,
and I live in a predominantly
Black neighborhood and teach
at a predominantly Black college,
and so the issue of race is one
that I deal with regularly.
And I just would be curious if
you had any words of suggestion
or advice for those of
us who regularly interact
with other races specifically
the Black-White dynamic
and you would say to young
people as well about all of that?
>> I would say to young people of
any background as I said to all
of you, let us not emphasize
difference and separation.
Let us emphasize what we have
in common and work together
that we don't just sit and
say I'm this and you're that.
But let us figure out what it is we
wanna do and what we want to achieve
and how we can do it together.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.